I think we have enough knowledge to begin tackling the mystery of the angle
and what do I mean by this.
We've shown that if we know, for example, what angle describes our position
and what I've called face space, which is somehow a relationship
between velocity and position, we can determine exactly what we are in the cycle
with this mass moving up and down, but how we do get this angle?
This angle seems so important. I don't know how to find it.
It seems to be related to position somehow, to velocity somehow, and also somehow to time,
because if I knew, for example, that I started here and released the mass from Xmax
as time went on, it would just trace out the circle.
And we've discussed a little bit what tracing the circle means.
So, I guess my question is, which variable can we use to determine this angle θ?
Is it velocity? position? or is it time?
This is a very tricky one but think it through and see if you can get the answer.